Everyone has bad dreams, whether they’re
about unconscious memories, showing up to
school in your underwear, or a man in a stripy
sweater with a spiky glove and a serious moisturizing
problem Nightmares are never far from us,
a common occurrence as part of the human experience,
and they can happen to anyone.
Of course, working for the SCP Foundation
means being faced with actual nightmares - not
only in the middle of the night - but on a
day-to-day basis.
Giant, unkillable lizards with pure hatred
for humanity, ancient eldritch beings with
enough cosmic power to wipe out entire dimensions,
and a species of busses with gigantic insect
legs that feed on human beings.
Needless to say, the researchers and operatives
that find themselves employed by the SCP Foundation
come face to face with some pretty horrific
creatures, enough to give anyone sleepless
nights.
This naturally begs the question: What could
possibly scare the workers of the SCP Foundation?
What could the Foundation possibly have nightmares
about?
Well, they don’t really have a name for
him, just a designation: SCP-990.
Multiple members of Foundation staff have
all made reports of witnessing the same entity.
After all, when you deal with dangerous cognitohazards
for a living, it’s worth taking every unusual
occurrence seriously, instead of just relying
on the old “it’s just a dream” excuse.
Anyone from doctors and research personnel,
to Mobile Task Force operatives and those
working as anomaly-guarding security - every
person working for the Foundation is at risk
of an unwanted encounter with SCP-990.
The reports are all consistent, they all describe
a man, seemingly a human being.
This figure always seems to appear dressed
in a business suit, but not like you might
see a modern CEO or a Wall Street stockbroker
wearing.
Instead, SCP-990’s sense of fashion seems
to be at least a few decades out, and he seems
to favor wearing clothing more in line with
the style of the Cold War era.
Wait, that can’t be it, right?
The big bad boogeyman that terrorizes the
dreams of the SCP Foundation’s staff is
just… a man in a suit?
What is he, an IRS Agent?
Well, while SCP-990 might not be all that
scary to look at when compared to other frightening
anomalies like the haunting beaked visage
of the Plague Doctor, or the unknowable horror
that is SCP-096, it’s not the way he looks
that’s terrifying.
It’s the ominous warnings he carries with
him.
What is interesting is that, while most dreams
are usually our brains’ way of processing
our memories or real-world experiences and
anxieties, SCP-990 seems to have no recorded
existence beyond what has been reported by
staff.
He seems to exclusively exist within the dreams
of Foundation personnel, with absolutely none
of these people having witnessed or encountered
the suit-wearing man in the real world.
If there is, somewhere out there among the
seven billion people on Planet Earth, a man
who resembles SCP-990, then the Foundation
has been unsuccessful in tracking him down.
What’s more, is that there has never been
a single report from outside of the Foundation
– not one civilian or even any member of
another Group of Interest – that anyone
else has ever had a dream involving SCP-990.
For years now he’s been cropping up exclusively
in the nightmares of Foundation personnel,
but was first discovered a number of years
ago after several agents began to discuss
the fact that they had all experienced similar
dreams, all revolving around a mysterious
man in a Cold War-era business suit.
But then, he finally became known to the higher-ups
at the Foundation after one peculiar incident.
An agent had failed to report to his assigned
post at the right time, and from that moment
on, things would never be the same again.
After scouring the Foundation facility for
this missing agent, when fellow members of
personnel found him, he was fast asleep in
his quarters.
Doesn’t seem too unusual right?
After all, working at the SCP Foundation has
got to be pretty hard going, with some horrendous
overtime hours, so maybe the agent just needed
to catch up on some sleep by taking a quick
nap before the start of his shift.
Then again, eighteen whole hours is one hell
of a long nap.
That’s right, the man had been unconscious
for eighteen hours.
When they found him, fellow Foundation staff
were unable to awaken the sleeping agent,
his body having entered some form of short-term
coma.
Unsure if he would ever wake again, medical
personnel had the agent moved to the sick
bay on-site, where he was placed under surveillance
and continued his long sleep.
After almost two whole days, and an uninterrupted
forty-hour period of sustained sleep, the
agent finally awoke.
He was agitated, erratic - Clearly, something
had rattled him pretty severely.
The agent dashed out of his bed in the medical
bay and began frantically running through
the corridors of the Foundation facility,
screaming and babbling about the impending
end of the entire world.
Eventually, medics were able to restrain the
man, injecting him with powerful sedatives
to relax him long enough for them to secure
him.
Yet somehow, the agent’s bodily functions
remained in a heightened state even after
he was sedated; his heart was beating at a
dangerously accelerated rate and his blood
pressure was spiking to quite an alarming
degree.
Now, we might not be medical experts, but
we can guarantee that high blood pressure
and an elevated heart rate are rarely ever
good signs.
Then again, neither is being asleep and unable
to wake up for forty solid hours.
As you may have already guessed, when he finally
calmed down, the agent described a dream that
revolved around a man dressed in a business
suit that seemed to match the styles of the
Cold War era.
In other words, SCP-990.
But you see, it’s not like the mysterious
man trapped the agent in this forty-hour dream
just to torture him.
There was no pulling the agent through the
center of his mattress causing a volcanic
eruption of blood to splatter up to the ceiling.
SCP-990 didn’t wrap any bed sheets around
the agent’s neck, or slash at him using
a glove with a blade at the end of each finger.
Instead, all SCP-990 did during the course
of the agent’s dream was deliver a message.
Well, actually it was more of a warning than
anything else.
After he had awoken and calmed down from his
prior outburst, the agent was being evaluated
by a Foundation doctor.
During this evaluation, the agent was able
to describe, in the most acute, precise detail
imaginable, a chilling sequence of events.
Something that was so accurate that it could
only have been true, instead of just an inconsequential
dream, or a fabricated, made-up story.
The agent was describing exactly how the world
was going to end.
Not a single detail was omitted, the exact
times and dates, the tipping of every domino
on the geopolitical landscape that would ultimately
lead to annihilation.
SCP-990 had appeared in the agent’s dream
to describe exactly how, at some point in
time, a series of events would culminate in
multiple tactical nuclear warheads being launched.
These deadly weapons of mass destruction would
head straight for targets in Central Europe
and eastern Asia, seeming to imply that the
missiles were to be launched by the United
States of America.
The resulting devastation of the nuclear payload
would wipe out almost the entirety of the
human race, exterminating around ninety-eight
percent of the planet’s population.
Society would collapse on a global scale,
and the world would be rendered a barren,
inhospitable wasteland ravaged by radioactive
fallout.
Every detail of this impending apocalypse
was relayed to the agent by SCP-990, including
exactly who and what would trigger the initial
chain of events destined to end in total destruction
of Earth.
Deciding to take the mysterious suited man’s
message seriously, the SCP Foundation dispatched
one of its elite Mobile Task Forces to eliminate
that initial threat, removing the thing that
would topple the first domino.
While the crisis was averted, and the world
saved, the agent who first reported his encounter
with SCP-990 died, suffering symptoms resembling
severe shock.
Of course, just because you manage to stop
one approaching apocalypse, doesn’t mean
that there won’t be others.
In fact, when you think about it, that’s
the scariest thing about SCP-990.
It’s not that he appears in Foundation personnel’s
dreams, it’s that his work is never done.
He always brings with him a new warning of
a new disaster on the horizon.
If anything, the ripples caused by preventing
one of these crises only create another to
deal with.
Since this initial incident, now designated
as Event-990-07, SCP-990 has made a number
of similarly ominous warnings through the
nightmares of other members of the SCP Foundation.
Any one of this business suit-wearing omen’s
warnings come with an almost one hundred percent
certainty rate.
He can foresee the future without any margin
of error, successfully predicting the exact
dates, times, and causes of the deaths of
multiple doctors working for the Foundation.
Even the destruction of a noted facility,
known as Watch Station Epsilon 38, was foretold
by an appearance of SCP-990.
Of course, theories about who or what exactly
this man is are common, but with no clear,
definitive answer to speak of.
It’s currently up in the air if this entity
is some sort of guardian angel, helping the
SCP Foundation protect humanity from their
own downfall and guiding us all to safety.
Or he could be a visitor from an infinite
number of potential futures, projecting himself
back in time to avert whatever course of action
led to the end of the world.
The staff at the SCP Foundation are encouraged
to come forward if they ever have a nocturnal
encounter with SCP-990, with one doctor even
believing that the man has a physical body
somewhere out there in the real world.
During one dream with SCP-990 in it, a Foundation
doctor was able to conduct a complete interview
with the man.
Now, we all know that it can be pretty tricky
to recall the details of a dream after waking
up, but this particular doctor claimed to
have an almost impeccable memory.
It’s unclear how exactly this doctor was
able to converse so clearly with SCP-990,
but with so many people working for the Foundation,
perhaps it was only a matter of time before
the man in the suit found one capable of lucid
dreaming.
At the commencement of this dream interview,
when asked for his name, SCP-990 responded
with ‘Tony’, as if he had pulled the name
from thin air.
When the doctor asked if this was his real
name, SCP-990 claimed that a person should
have the right to be called whatever they
wish to be called, before changing his mind
and asking to be called Richard instead.
The doctor pressed on, asking the man why
he had been delivering threats to Foundation
personnel through their dreams.
SCP-990 seemed confused by this.
Then, the doctor rebutted by accusing the
dream walker of murdering the agent, the one
who had first reported his encounter with
SCP-990.
Hearing this, the entity explained that the
Foundation had the wrong impression of him,
claiming he wasn’t the bad guy.
Upon mention of a ‘bad guy’ being involved,
the doctor’s next course of action was naturally
to ask who this might be.
And then SCP-990 said something even stranger:
it was the designation of another SCP.
But not one that the Foundation had ever encountered
before, there didn’t even exist any anomaly
under the number that the mysterious dream
man had given.
“There is no SCP with that designation,
and there won't be for some time,” the doctor
argued, growing ever more confused and agitated.
“Well of course not,” SCP-990 replied.
“She hasn't even been born yet, much less
classified by your Foundation.”
When asked if this was another prediction
of an impending disaster, yet another threat
that could end the entire world, SCP-990 simply
told the doctor “This is your wake-up call.”
Since then, no one is certain who or what
this future anomaly could be, whether she
has since been contained by the Foundation
or if that is still yet to come.
The sad part about our dreams is they only
ever really offer us a look backwards, memories
and experiences all warped in our sleeping
brains.
None of us can look forward, nobody knows
exactly what the future holds.
Well, none of us except SCP-990, that is.
It’s been a long time since the Foundation
designated SCP-990.
If that prophesied nightmare of an SCP has
been born and designated since then, what
do you think she is?
Let us know down in the comments.
Now go check out “SCP-3017 - The Most Dangerous
Person Alive” and “SCP 1440 - The Old
Man That Kills All Living Things He Touches”
for more eerie humanoid SCPs!